I was 12 years old I was 13 years old I
was 12 years old I was 13 years old when
I was bullied when I was bullied there
were confrontations in hallways it was
pretty much directly face-to-face verbal
contact I was being called a name from
my so-called friends some person that I
don't know slam my head into the locker
and called me a [ __ ] and they just
walked away I was dealing with a lot of
you know acne problems this guy he would
just call me pizza face in front of
people I was just walking through the
cafeteria and someone called me a [ __ ]
it was kind of like my whole body had
chills and I didn't know what to do they
all giggled and laughed and it actually
was a word in Cantonese and I don't
speak Cantonese I think now I would say
like same way what they were calling me
was little fat girl this kid turned
around to me with a sharpie marker and
for all the classmates to hear and it
said hey Zac bend over I want to play
connect the dots with your face I was so
embarrassed when it happened bullies
made me feel so bad about my ethnicity
like I really did internalize that it
made me feel like I wasn't as good as
anybody else I didn't really know what
is friendship if the people that you
think you're close to are laughing at
you it was something that was really
heartbreaking for my mom to see I
remember she just always looked so sad
for me because I was just being myself
and me being myself meant that I was
being bullied you just have this fear in
middle school in high school that you're
going to be called that
for the rest of your life now it's a
word that I look back on and I use it to
see how far I've come
you know I realized that that's not who
I am I haven't been that since I was you
know 13 14 years old no matter what
people think I can accomplish anything
that I want I was doing great things I
great friends a great family I love my
life and I am more than just a little
fat girl that word does not define me it
never did define me
I'm so much more as a person I could be
whoever I wanted to be and I was
extremely proud of being Asian I am
great I am happy I am anything that I
want to be there's going to be a time
where you realize that the thing that
people target you for is actually your
greatest asset I recommend building a
support system and help each other learn
that you are more than those words if
you be yourself and you grow up to be
who you want to be you're going to be a
great person no matter what you are so
much more than any of the words that
anyone could say to you
Wow